[Music]
one of the starts that I talked to
backstage was Ray J and he is one of the
victims of Chania Amos video which I'm
sure you've heard about by now it is
outrageous to say the least and has
everyone from Kanye and Kim to Taylor
Swift and Donald Trump depicted naked in
bed together but here's the thing kindly
being Kanye he tweeted
can somebody sue me we think that's a
really good and valid question did you
know that was my marriage is all messed
up because of craziness cuz I'm not I'm
not a part of nothing crazy so Ray J
Kim's ex who made a very famous video
with her and he's naked next to her in
this video at least a wax figure of him
is he's no stranger to stirring up
controversy in the name of art but
hasn't gone too far this time but may
come to mind it's defamation libel
intentional infliction of emotional
distress I wouldn't be surprised if
there is a lawsuit that will ensue but
it could be an uphill battle according
to attorney Michael and Cohen there's a
defense that Kanye can make a First
Amendment defense a parody and in free
speech he said himself that his life is
a walking art exhibit or it's a
commentary on Fame so he's setting
himself up smartly the video premiered
Friday night at the LA forum to a
sold-out crowd and streamed live on
tidal Kim and the rest of the Kardashian
clan were there but there's been little
reaction so far
et reached out to Taylor Swift she is
yet to speak out Chris Brown who's seen
alongside his ex Rihanna voiced one
complaint saying why I gotta have the
plumbers butt cracks showing
wax figure and a rep for President Bush
told us in case there's any question the
observant person will notice the
President Bush is in much better shape
want to add two things real quick
Brandon Scott Disick coming out of
Beatty Awards last night and I asked why
weren't you in the famous video and he
said
enough and then I talked to French
Montana who was very tight with the
family was there during the unveiling
and he said Connie did a great job of
keeping this secret he had no idea well
I gotta say those love him or hate him
there she gotta say about Kanye he had
us all talking once again and that's
what they said about great art if you're
calling the great art look I will refuse
to call Kim Kardashian's but great art
okay I'm sure there's somebody out there
who will